dans les métros du pays depuis la
pandémie chez les usagers montréalés les
expériences
varients ça dérange probablement des
usagers qui ont peur qui ont peur d'être
agressé ou d'être insulté une fois les
rencontres des personnes sont
dans le texte des personnes qui font la
publicité on envoie moins dans le métro
j'ai vu que voir beaucoup plus de
policiers ici on pourrait faire une
équipe de sécurité spéciale la société
transport reçoit en tout cas plus de
plaintes associées au tabagisme
consommation d'alcool et de drogues
ainsi que pour comportement violent ou
irrespectueux 662 en 2020 716 en 2021 et
983 en 2022 en 25 jours cette année 125
plaintes avaient été déjà déposées par
des usagers
de l’achatendage n'y est pas anodine
selon la STM qui assure adapter ses
stratégies aux réalités sur le terrain
nous notre clientèle nos employés c'est
bien laisser bien les outils
je mentionnais tantôt la formation qui
la formation vraiment en visant sur la
désescalade la formation qui est offerte
à nos employés sur le terrain la STM
collaborent aussi avec le
c'est les organismes communautaires au
quotidien je vous dirais que on se fait
agresser puis comme je vous dis ça peut
aller des agressions verbales pour le
président du syndicat des chauffeurs
d'autobus la situation est inquiétante
et les formations ne sont plus
suffisantes la solution comme je vous
dis c'est qu'il faut avoir plus de
surveillance mais en dehors des
surveillance les cabines assez
agressions c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut extrêmement
envisager avec toute transport en commun
à Toronto les agressions violentes
d'usagers et d'employés de la commission
transport font les manchettes depuis
près d'un an à Edmonton deux employés
ont récemment été menacés d'une arme un
syndicat national tire la sonnette
d'alarme
l'action immédiate dit-il passe par plus
de visibilité policière mais aussi du
financement de soutien en santé mentale
dans les communautés et la formation des
travailleurs aux techniques de
désescalade ici Camille Radio-Canada
Montréal